harrison new jersey is home to the
spanish pavilion located a mile and a
half from newark's historic ironbound
neighborhood an area highly populated by
spanish restaurants
[Music]
the spanish pavilion was opened by a man
ahead of his time antonio fernandez my
grandfather was a pioneer in the spanish
cuisine he opened up in 1964 the first
spanish restaurant in the state of new
jersey he retired after 10 years very
successful and then came out of
retirement to open the spanish pavilion
in 1976. antonio finally retired for
good in 1996 leaving the successful
spanish pavilion to his daughter balbina
and her two sons jerry and michael table
11 please ma when we took over the
spanish pavilion was the place to be
there was a line out the door five years
later
everything's still going down the tubes
the customers complain up you see the
same old menus the same old dishes
enough flavor blend oh flavor that sauce
is good i don't care we're like a casual
family restaurant and we have to wear a
tuxedo and you're serving people with
shorts and t-shirts it just doesn't
match looks like
you're in a wedding party in 1973.
michael and jerry they don't care
anymore they don't like to put time in
the business where's my brother
my colero valero stopped cooking you
gotta be here more often and now it's
out of the kitchen more out than in i'm
dying to have a drink my staff might
complain that i'm not here a lot but as
far as i'm concerned i don't know what
i'm doing jerry doesn't do anything so
the mayor's coming to pick up lunch he's
always on the phone he's always this
he's always that
i'm a councilman in my town tomorrow
night we'll celebrate victory i smell it
in the air and i am out of here more but
sometimes i don't want to be here enough
because
michael can get a little tough what the
hell happened to this [ __ ] hey with
the lobster [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] screaming and yelling and i guess
it kind of wears you out you know
there's a real easy solution for this
[ __ ] problem michael what stop it
michael stop it michael and jerry have a
lot of differences and i find myself in
the middle i don't want to hear any more
about the situation too bad
my mother is at this restaurant right
now just to make sure that my brother
and i do not kill each other what do you
need huh
nothing get out of here this place needs
big time help i don't know what to do on
a saturday night maybe i'll do 10 15 20
dinners
that's not paying the bills i still
haven't even paid my fish guy i gotta
pay my fish guy we're in the debt over
five or six hundred thousand dollars i'm
scared we can't support our families on
this business so it's a stress
i'll do anything it takes to succeed
spanish pavilion is all i got
[Music]
hello hi hello how are you how are you
somebody dying
did somebody pass away
no one no you all look immaculately
formal but tuxedos undertakers at a
funeral how old are those suits they are
beautiful huh made to measure thank you
thank you thank you thank you wow wow
these guys are stuck back in the 80s
they look like little penguins and
they're wobbling back and forth with
their little you know little tuxedos hi
how are you slightly on the dress my
apologies you're you're okay i'm very
nervous about chef ramsay coming into
the restaurant i wasn't a fan of this
idea michael was
and i'm a little nervous i'm the mom
okay great so my first name excuse me
balbina where's that from from spain oh
wow would you like to come to the table
i'd love to
this will be joe he'll be here sir
welcome to spanish pavilion very happy
to see another unique tuxedo wow thank
you very much you wear this every day
for lunch yes
anyway so when did the spanish pavilion
move 1976. wow take me back to what it
was like in his day
my grandfather worked seven days a week
at 75 he would jump behind the broiler
and do the meat i mean if he were in his
prime right now i know he would be doing
a better job than we would you're here
five days i'm out a little more lately
because i was elected as a committeeman
in my town politician yeah i enjoy it i
really do generally don't care for the
business anymore if you know this
business you cannot be do politicians or
something else my brother and i both
went to johnson and wales university for
this and i worked at the front of the
house my brother did more of the
culinary end and he's the chatty
cuisine mike call him a chef
to me
he's not a chef
he's always playing on the phone instead
of cooking for the customers he um well
i don't know if he's the chef
but he's in back there quite a bit thank
you have a little read no problem thank
you
listen and no playing around right now i
don't worry about it we're gonna nail
this
put your phone away
are you ready oh yes let's start off
with lobster biscuits okay sir um i'll
go for the uh maria
marinara is one of the house specialties
wonderful another dish that people are
gonna please the chicken and garlic
sauce on the bone love it again i walked
in i thought it was a funeral now i'm in
spain you've got me back okay brilliant
i hope you guys
yeah i can't wait
i'm gonna make sure you got nothing to
do with disorder
i ain't hanging my boys to drive but
i'm so confident overseeing my guys that
i got nothing to worry about these guys
been by my side 15 years no go go go man
go
let's see what he thinks
it just looks disgusting
like cream is always this creamy yes
it just looks like lobster was dead
before they killed him they're from
the lobsters from the tank you want to
take a look okay
is he dead
no i think they're just sleeping
you must be dead we keep a good eye on
this you keep a good eye on them surely
not
he's [ __ ] dead a dead lobster
no he's gone is he
what i'm concerned about is everything
else in there they've been feeding off
that lobster then they become
full of bacteria
that is extremely unacceptable dangerous
people can get extremely sick with that
i'll get rid of this right now okay
please
all right love you bye
we should melt it
[Music]
it don't smell that lobster's fresh even
though it died it's
good this is my bro my baby hey michael
pretty good good i'm doing fine thank
you i know you saw a lobster in there
that passed away well i try to we try to
check that every day i was just slightly
concerned to see the dead lobsters in
there i try to freeze them right away
and then i make the best from there okay
you must be busy yeah thank you enjoy
thank you
okay i'm gonna serve you right now the
chicken and garlic sauce
olive oil garlic we've got a little bowl
they just drink some of that out it's
like they're swimming
thank you
oh dear it's like a [ __ ] exxon
valdeza too much olive oil for you
you think there's too much olive oil in
there
it's like a heart attack waiting to
happen i hope there's a hospital nearby
the chicken tastes absolutely dreadful
i just want you to taste the chicken
just taste that
literally it's dry you sound like a
politician now
jerry i'm not [ __ ] around that's
gross do me a favor can you ask your
brother to taste that
yeah want you to try this
what what's the next dish
fire
send a fire
the paella
what did michael say he's trying it
right now we're not fine
what do you have to say
i thought it was [ __ ] good i'll tell
him that
have faith on me baby this ain't a
normal guy it's a bread huh they're pain
in the neck
he thought it was [ __ ] good
wow
if he thought that was [ __ ] good that
i'm screwed if you're screwed imagine
how i am
and this is the uh marinara the lobster
in this boyer did it come from the tank
it comes from the tank
oh [ __ ]
okay
or would you be so kind to taste it for
me
yeah no
badly badly seasoned yeah
it does overcook this is ridiculous that
this pan even came out
add respect for your granddad that
is a joke
give me five minutes we'll have a chat
together
yeah please
thank you
uh chef like some
dessert it's very kind but i've lost my
appetite thank you
are you doing stuff purposely wrong or
is this
i mean is that
is overcooked all right all right you go
sit and listen and he's right about
everything nothing i can do about that
right now
i feel utterly embarrassed and
humiliated the way food went out the way
it did it killed me okay i'm gonna get
straight to the point shitbisk
dead lobsters and the player
that burnt [ __ ] at the bottom this is
your grandfather that put this thing
together was he sending food out like
that no what was wrong with the chicken
and garlic the chicken was way
overcooked maybe the pizza you had it
was dry but i finished the plate
did you cook that dish
no i did not cook any dishes here today
[Music]
what do you actually do michael i don't
taste everything but i try to taste as
much as i can
[Music]
you're the last line of defense
out of every dish that i had there today
what did you taste of mine every single
one
at least when it came back
when it came back if your grandfather
was sat on my table today they'd be
beating the crap out of you i'm proud of
what went out today
this is the food i do this is how they
cook it and i know the food over here is
good you're [ __ ] dreaming michael
hi how are you
enjoy your meal welcome to spanish
pavilion after an afternoon that
included a dead lobster in the tank a
miserable lunch and a head chef that
doesn't cook chef ramsay is anxious to
observe a dinner service at spanish
pavilion
[Music]
chicken rice i'm gonna try the toyo
i'll pick my own laughs over here from
laughter thanks for your time coming up
where's michael he's just sitting at the
bar at the bar how you doing bro
nice to see you michael
can we get ready i'm ready jerry
ready see how ready you are
no one's really in the back of the house
you know observing and making sure
everything's 100
i think my brother should be monitoring
that watching it despite head chef
michael being absent from the kitchen
dishes are being sent out there
they're here already
unfortunately they're all on the cook
you want me to cook them a little more
and just not done enough
enough they're also coming back said
these are undercooked and a little chewy
undercooked yeah they're right big raw
on the inside look at that
that's completely raw this is raw
yup is this normal yes it happened a lot
of times it shows happened but they
happen a lot of times the kitchen have
on our system there's no one person in
charge in the kitchen it's supposed to
be mic
with dishes coming back michael jumps
back into the kitchen this came back
michael what was this i don't know what
that is but so does jerry and both
brothers are trying to take control of
the kitchen michael yeah take this off
the window right now i don't know what
you're playing at john driving me nuts
i won't let my brother dictate what i do
or how i run my business give me those
crab legs right now legs have to be
finished michael do what you're doing
stop cooking do what you're doing i am
doing what i'm doing i'm telling you
about them snow crabs
mike
can anyone work together here i mean
this is absolutely [ __ ] hideous king
crab legs are already out no this is
just snow no there's no kink crave legs
out my god it was gonna take this long i
would have definitely had something
before we left
hopefully it's worth the wait though you
get involved you know you confuse me see
give me the only i take is the yellow
teeth
listen to me listen to me give me a pork
chop meet him mike was in the middle you
tried to do everything and you know he
got conf he confuses a lot of people i
need an order of spanish potatoes and
rice
and i want together are separate it
doesn't matter i don't know
separate stop yelling i'll knock you out
right here you hear me we need to get
organized big time everyone can argue
with each other
no teamwork anywhere no i want that i'm
gonna go home in a minute okay me too i
gotta go home too
okay give me no it's not happening to me
give me those lobsters no people are
waiting okay they're right here what do
you want them up your ass oh minnie give
them to me i'll take them out mike
keep it together listen give me that
[ __ ] food i want to send out i want
all right i [ __ ] put out let's come
here come here with me i want the
[ __ ] food out leave
give me the food that i want the
customers are waiting for the food
everything you can yeah we're okay we're
okay
i understand you're excited right now
you're gonna be alone
it's two hours into dinner service
that's completely raw with dishes being
returned and very little food leaving
the kitchen give me the food that i want
the customers are waiting for the food
there's now chaos in spanish pavilion i
want the [ __ ] food out leave me a
[ __ ] room
and it's all too much for michael what's
that [ __ ] lady i gotta have here
michael okay
get out of here
stop it get out of here michael what's
the matter with you
stop and stop it out michael stop it ah
no way
you're jumping around give me the food
give me the real michael michael okay
okay okay okay michael come here better
listen relax relax relax relax just stop
stop
i'm michael you're a [ __ ] owner just
boom
big deep breath what are you doing what
are you doing to that man this guy is
here to help you i know what then what
the [ __ ] are you doing michael should
never touch somebody no stop it
i got no right to do that michael should
not do that that's where my brother
sometimes doesn't get it let's get back
in normal here go take a breather
is that me my brother
yeah um
he can get he can flip like this
sometimes yeah it can work like that
[Music]
jumping around like a maniac
[Music]
calm down calm down calm down
uh michael calm down calm down michael
you calm down now and stop making a big
show out of it i'm not mine stop it i
was the one that made the show out of
this again it's just
stopping it's my fault
stop it yeah
i lost my temperature in the heat of the
moment it happens but you gotta calm
down regroup and just breathe
with michael cooling off outside
hey the kitchen manages to pull it
together five's ready take it out
sending out the last orders of the night
have a good night
thank you
okay uh
what are they
i've never ever seen
such a disorganized fragmented service
ever
[Music]
disaster
confusion in the kitchen
chaos in the dining room lots of
confusion
michael
i thought you were supposed to be
running the kitchen
i don't think you realize how bad
tonight was
i see in the morning
[Music]
after a night in which 21 dishes came
back during dinner service that's
completely raw oh my god this is raw
chef ramsay comes in early to do a
little investigating what is in there
they're not drumsticks
they're crab sticks just dumped in here
top off another bag
of alaskan crab
no dates no labels
how on earth are you supposed to run a
business when you've got no idea what's
in the freezers
always down here
my god it gets worse look at it it's
absolutely jam-packed
chicken after chicken after chicken
my big worry is how much chicken does
this restaurant really need i mean
there's just bags of it
and not only that but
the smell is
horrific oh my god
look at these fillets i've seen less
packs at an army base it's over 50 packs
of meat
and whoever's buying this needs to be
fired now what worries me about this is
there's one more fridge upstairs
[Music]
what's that
[ __ ] pigeon
oh my god it's never ending just when i
think i've seen enough there's more
look dead
decomposed soft dead
oh that's the snails
what is that in there
that is a raw dead lobster that is
disgusting it's two hours into chef
ramsay's inspection
michael balbina and jerry arrive unaware
of what chef ramsay is doing and what he
has uncovered
morning good morning
i just need you for two minutes
who in the hell buys produce here who
who's responsible for that i am you are
[ __ ] pigeon
what i'm trying to look at are the
profits they're purchasing the thousands
of dollars waste
these here
[Music]
they came in yesterday that's dead
let's have a look around here
jerry please
and you wonder why i don't like your
sauce
that is a dead lobster
[Music]
and the freshest thing in this kitchen
is that pigeon flying around and he's
lucky he's still alive
i thought that the kitchen wasn't
somewhat disarray did i think it was
that bad no i'd love to turn around and
say that's it
have you seen what's downstairs in the
fridge
where do i start with this
look at all this [ __ ] meat here
i wanted to make sure i was ready
ready for what whatever help me michael
ready for what my way whatever came your
way don't know what to expect you're
burning money you haven't got
why is this like this
what happened michael somebody's not
doing their job in in the kitchen
there's expensive produce here this is
ridiculous
[Music]
yeah my fault and my fault when i
refrigerated
i'm disappointed that so much was
ordered in advance there's no excuse for
that
spend some time together i've got to
wash my [ __ ] hands before i get
diagnosed with [ __ ] staphylococci
you need to concentrate you know what
maybe i'm overwhelmed mom maybe i'm
trying to do everything and i can't
maybe the office the ordering what's the
most important i
i gotta iron that out man this is the
most important and i
try my hardest
i don't know what to tell you about
about all this meat and everything here
i'm out of here right now
it's overwhelming i just don't have the
answers
[Music]
this is so sad you know that
what would your father say if he walked
in here and saw that
no my father
of course would be upset what i saw down
there today
it's not the spanish pavilion
it's not what i was brought into the
quality of the food meant a lot to my
father it's upsetting and i would hope
things wouldn't get to the extreme that
i have to close the doors i don't know
right now what's going through his mind
but his concentration right now is
totally off he's all over the place his
shows
jerry has to put in a little more too
and when he's here he should concentrate
on
the restaurant forget all your politics
jerry needs michael michael needs jerry
they now have to roll up their sleeves
work together but more importantly
we're going to set the differences aside
as brothers and stop being so stubborn
because that's what they are and the
business is fragmented
[Music]
today chef ramsay is determined to move
the spanish pavilion in the right
direction and he knows one step is
getting michael back to where he belongs
i want you to think of something that
you want to cook in the kitchen cooking
something that go on tonight as a
special yes chef
right out of college i had a lot of
passion i had a lot of creativity i
would come up with dishes a little
easier but i don't know if i'm going to
be able to come up with something that's
going to impress the chef right first of
all i want to do a chicken and garlic
yeah a modern version i want you to work
with me at the same time
i started off with olive oil start off
with butter it's going to
i'm excited about having the opportunity
to learn from one of the top five most
famous chefs in the world you got that
nice saute cereal on the chicken
from there you put it over the top
and then just scoop up a touch of that
sauce
modern
spanish cuisine what do you think that
you want to cook my grandfather's really
well known for some octopus
okay and i want to make some octopus
with nice go for it
i'm nervous right now i hope this dish
comes out right through the years i've
lost some of my passion for this kitchen
so far it looks good i know that chef
ramsay can help me by bringing my
passion back
and i'm looking forward to it this is
the octopus
okay and
roast potatoes yes
yeah good it's nice yeah i like it
presentation as well i like
it and tonight want you this side of the
line right
yeah
yeah chef
chef ramsay's chicken and garlic dish
and michael's octopus special are going
on tonight's menu the chicken dish
is a modern version of a garlic chicken
but after serving the same old menu read
the special back to me
i'm sorry
20-year veteran joe is having a hard
time with the change
chicken our chef on the bone or the
garlic chicken chef on the bone come on
you can do it joe yeah but you're making
me nervous now i'm making you nervous
yes
just put your head in there for two
minutes cool it down head in there
that's it
stay there for two minutes
[Music]
hi how are you follow me please thank
you enjoy okay guys let's go yeah
chef ramsay knows the success of this
restaurant depends on jerry and michael
working together michael yes sir i want
to look at you yeah and i want this
level of communication
much better than we had last night so
tonight both brothers are assigned to do
what they do best michael cooking behind
the line all right listen try to take
care of this area and jerry running the
pass michael listen to me
look at me one minute if the [ __ ] hits
the fan i want you to listen to me yes
sir no i mean yes okay
i gotta admit i'm a little nervous right
now i don't know what to expect i'm
afraid of failure i might [ __ ] up
but just remind me we can handle this
all right we're gonna see
the chicken today is the chicken uh our
chef a little uh for wine called dress
from spain cherry cherry wine
okay
lemon juice and a little touch of butter
here goes the first stick here right
let me have a chicken special my first
order comes in there's a special one
right
it's good it's good it's like perfect
bro but it scares me i just don't trust
i can see it in his eyes he's a little
nervous
so hopefully we'll go to the night okay
i'll take that chicken and garlic out
first one of the night go table six
despite michael's lack of confidence i'm
not gonna be able to do it the specials
are not only leaving the kitchen oh wow
the customers this is really good are
thrilled with what they are receiving
delicious i like it wow with the dining
room now full and orders pouring into
the kitchen
i don't know what's going on michael not
used to being on the line is starting to
buckle under the pressure all right give
me table three or six
we got to get this food out there's no
rush
well there's a little bit of a pressing
now we'll let him wait
well it's been taking off a long time
uh joe
joe is it me or food's taking a long
time to come out yes that's it too slow
way too slow
tables are gonna get up and leave in 10
seconds i need table 13. it's about four
three minutes away don't keep asking but
we have all these tables waiting for
food and michael is overwhelmed with his
kitchen duties
and i need him to focus ah
just put it on a [ __ ] plate right now
come on guys as tensions escalate in the
kitchen very little food is making its
way out to the dining room
and one customer who was lucky enough to
receive food the chicken's dry
isn't exactly happy ever had chip
i didn't like it cherry
it's not normal
it's not [ __ ] normal that one chicken
it just didn't smell right
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
oh no
jerry yeah
michael yeah chef urgently quickly
smell let's go no smell it
don't just say [ __ ] yeah it's gone
you can't serve that [ __ ] tonight
i felt utterly embarrassed and
humiliated at this point we're just
going to shut it down oh stop stop
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service
and while jerry and michael continue to
clash in the kitchen just put it on the
[ __ ] plate right now
chef ramsay discovers something
disturbing oh no spoiled chicken in the
spanish pavilion you can't serve that
[ __ ] tonight
oh no
ow
have you got chicken in the fryer did
you pass that chicken hey i don't want
it don't serve it don't don't [ __ ]
dare sal go get me a chicken let's cut
an order real quick fresh right now
michael how many fresh chickens are
downstairs a case and a half
a cake and a half downstairs in the
[ __ ] fridge
and he's serving you that sticky [ __ ]
you're cooking it and it's off
you know i don't know why that chicken
got there we got fresh chickens
downstairs you know what we got to use
that fresh chicken then but
when you're in the weeds you have to
focus all right we have the chicken and
garlic they're using the one for
downstairs thank you
if you're going to keep the customers
waiting you've got to make sure it's
right
i'm not going to let it crumble go get
it
we got to get this food out give me that
chicken and garlic let's go jerry you'll
get the chicken of garlic when it's done
please out out give me table two [ __ ]
this give me table too that's it with
jerry clearly stepping up as the leader
take this to table two the evening is
salvaged and food is leaving the kitchen
once again
everything's coming out right now at the
end of the day getting that food out is
like a relief thank you you might have
had to wait like an hour but we'll get
it down eventually
honestly tonight was better
every like the specials
but let's not get too excited about
tonight because the quality control has
to be much better you're absolutely
right and michael your cooks are passing
you
stinking rancid chicken but you didn't
spot it
jerry
i thought your performance tonight
was bloody good
thank you sir
tonight was better
hopefully we're headed in the right
direction good night
[Music]
with the spanish pavilion at least
headed in the right direction chef
ramsay and his team work overnight to
give the spanish pavilion a modern
makeover
good morning good morning good morning
jeff good to see you all
let's be honest not much has changed
over the last 30 years right correct
today is the beginning of a new era and
through that door
is your future are you ready to see it
yes
michael are you ready
one two
three
come on in
look at this oh my god
nice that's what i'm talking about
great
warm inviting atmosphere we removed the
stained glass to give it a modern feel
unreal and then down here we've
increased the seating
so we have a lovely bank heads
tablecloths
have gone gone all the tables have been
replaced
this is walnut it's modern and it's warm
on the table tops we have the most
amazing china oh baby provided by table
tops unlimited awesome how exciting is
that i love it baby it's amazing i feel
like i'm in another restaurant i
couldn't believe the openness of the
dining room glad to see the tablecloths
gone the new plates the spanish look i
felt like i was in spain it's awesome
nice
following the much needed redesign chef
ramsay now turns his attention to
attracting new customers
when your grandfather opened his
restaurant there he did not face the
competition that you now face
i really do mean
competition
look
at that
2010 40 spanish restaurants within a
two-mile radius of your front door
having studied in the neighbourhood all
these russians are serving the same
bloody food
you have an opportunity now to stand out
are you ready to see your dishes oh yes
come with me let's go
please come through
small tapas is the taste of spain
authentic delicious and homemade you
have to push the tapas this is what
turns this ration around a roasted lamb
spanish meatball and a fresh tomato
sauce
bacon wrapped dates yes sauteed prawns
with garlic a little bit of shaved
fennel
olives manchego cheese yeah we're going
for flavor simplicity and we're going
for spain
i love the new menu to be different is
incredible that is the key to make our
restaurant stand out but just as
important here are your new waiters come
here come here come here come here look
at these guys come here
amazing
they now no longer look like undertakers
look at this look
i look good
i love this guy
okay tonight is your night there's
nothing you cannot do here yeah good
luck thank you
[Music]
chef an order comes in who's touching
that ticket who do you think jerry
that's right
he's excited i want to give it right
there absolutely definitely
but jerry he's gonna lose the tickets
i'm afraid he will not lose it why are
you talking so negatively oh no i'm
trying to force you
don't foresee just focus right yeah yes
you're thinking too hard
it must hurt right now i have to trust
my brother and i don't know if i could
do that i'm worried that the whole thing
could fall apart
with over 40 spanish restaurants in two
square miles this is our new menu chef
ramsay's menu overhaul will now have the
spanish pavilion standing out the
croquetas is great excellent and then
we'll do um
paella but will the brothers be able to
pull it off here we go first order
coming in one meatball one manchego
croquettes and the clams with chorizo
come on guys this first order we got to
do it right
table two appetizers go
i'm sending you a potato drivers one
dates table 11. okay looks wonderful
brother okay let's go this is gone let's
go after that's a rock-a-lam meeting
how is it fantastic yummy how is it it's
good yeah yeah i like it
so spicy and tasty i love it i think
they'd love those chocolate places
as the dining room fills up another
order coming in orders continue to pour
in and it's time for the kitchen to face
its first big test send me that table
six table six didn't we send down that
went out six one no it did six went out
cherry or maybe not no it didn't no it
didn't know what it is
all right two meatballs no michael table
six doesn't have any meatballs michael
let jerry do his job
i think michael's overwhelmed and he
doesn't focus that's what we have to
deal with almost every day with michael
that's it go 17.
jerry whoa oh you got the crook at the
sherry she left without him for whom the
water is one muscles
no
no you're right you're right you're
right get organized buddy
yeah
put a [ __ ] rabbit in a headlight look
at him let's go
michael's confusion in the kitchen turns
the dining room i wonder what's taking
them so long
into a waiting room
michael listen to me
michael you know listen
and jerry's attempt to restore the
communication i need listen to me listen
to me
falls on deaf ears i need a strip right
now shop table five started seven get
their appetite table five no table seven
did not but before table seven i need
table five it's not gonna cook any
quicker than where you asked for it
brother
right do you you hey step up to the
market a little bit okay i'm work with
your team we all know michael feels that
he has to be in control at all times
jerry it's my line
so the reality is if the person on the
other side of the line is expediting the
food that person is the orchestra leader
he's got to listen to that person no
matter what
right now i'm that person michael you
have table seven over there please
didn't that go out no give me three
skirt states over there right away right
here three one two three
[Music]
michael support
it's relaunch night at the spanish
pavilion and while the restaurant feels
new the mounting pressure has brought
out the old michael
and the restaurant is teetering on
disaster i need table five didn't that
go out no give me three skirt steaks
over there right away right here three
one two three
mike
come here
two seconds
you have to keep it together
he's your brother you can't do that in
front of the [ __ ] team
you've got to show him some [ __ ]
respect yes it's hard you've got to back
off
he's up to his eyeballs in the [ __ ]
weeds and you're laying into him [ __ ]
slow down
it's your brother and it's your business
and his business got it yeah sure come
on yes sir
chef rams is 100 right i cannot
argue with my brother
i overdid it man i made a mistake and it
won't happen again i'm gonna learn and
it's gonna be better right regroup and
organize after that
jerry what would you like i need those
clams
and i need the paella marinara for two
and then after that's a rock-a-layer
meeting in my hand sir
that's it right there right okay well
hot that's really hot okay got bugs
let's do the bar i need an order of
gamba i'm coming right now that's what i
need
with michael and jerry finally working
together i need patatas problems i'll be
right out that's what happens will be
right out the two brothers complete
dinner service
on a high
so good
that's your dessert very good
all right
okay okay this is good best spanish
restaurant in this area
[Music]
tonight confirmed that the spanish
pavilion is back on the map and ready to
compete
but tomorrow it starts all over again
tonight wasn't perfect but we did make
an amazing transformation thank you see
ya it was wonderful to meet you light
was lightweight light-wise it's just to
hear
the chef say you guys can do it really
got to my sons
you too 30 seconds in the bath please
together
for them to realize
if you work together
and you concentrate you got a good
business here
you have an amazing opportunity now to
really turn this restaurant around
but it requires both of you
jerry
i thought you were just some politician
you are a genuine leader thank you chef
thank you great potential
michael
a big heart but you've got to focus
behind that line if you stay focused
and master those dishes
you'll get there i promise you i will
i promise you chef ramsay came here and
i had the intentions that he was going
to help put this place back on track i
think he did more than what i expected i
think he ignited my passion in the
kitchen again put me closer with my
brother this is what we needed and look
after each other
good night
[Music]
when i first arrived here i was greeted
by a dead lobster and a restaurant stuck
in the 70s and in just a matter of days
the spanish pavilion has been
transformed but this russian will only
succeed
those two brothers find a way to stay
united and work together
big brother little brother
in the weeks that followed
okay take this to the table too give me
those jerry embraced his role as
expediter give me the free harvest and
is now devoting more time to the
restaurant and i need a filet mignon
medium well you have that working right
jerry meeting what i was waiting on
michael is staying in the kitchen let's
go there you go there you go there you
go and cooking full time
and the new menu is being well received
by the customers
more importantly these brothers are
united and carrying on the successful
legacy left to them by their grandfather
you